[APPLAUSE]
AMY BLANKSON: Hey, everyone.
Thank you so much
for having me here.
This is such a privilege to get
to be your first speaker here
in this new, awesome
space and to get to spend
the afternoon with you.
We're going to have
a lot of fun today.
And I have a few
experiments up my sleeve
that I'm looking forward
to subjecting you to.
And I also have some
information that I really
am hoping to share and
convey to you, some of which
you may already know
or you might already
feel validates who you are.
And some of the
information which I think
might challenge you or
be great information
to share with those of your
colleagues, friends, and family
members who weren't
able to be here today.
So I want to start off
with one statement that's
really beginning to challenge.
It was the beginning
and the genesis
of what caused me
to write my book
on "The Future of Happiness."
And it was a statement
I read that said,
technology is the greatest
disruptor of happiness
in human history.
And is that really true?
We hear news from
multiple different sources
about how technology is the
equivalent of digital heroin.
How there is screen
time that's eroding
the fabric of our society
and ruining our relationships
with our grandparents.
But some of this
information comes
from a sensationalized source.
And so I wanted to delve into,
what is the truth about this?
I come from a background in
positive psychology, which
is an odd place to
come to technology.
Most people think that
technology and happiness
are actually oxymorons.
But I think that
there's something really
important to be said for
the time and the place
that we're living in
that requires us to think
a little bit more
deeply about how we're
living in the digital age.
How can we live with greater
happiness and mindfulness
in the digital age?
Is this even possible, or is
it truly the greatest disrupter
of happiness in human history?
In the past 10
years, we have found
that technology has sped up
so dramatically that we find
ourselves overwhelmed and
unprepared for the challenges
that we face today.
We find that since the
iPhone came out in 2007,
we're now about a decade
out from the first iPhone,
that the world has
changed dramatically.
We have technology that
would have blown our minds 10
years ago, from FaceTime
to 3D printed organs that
are saving lives.
And yet at the same time, we're
finding that depression rates
have doubled in that
same period of time,
that the amount of cyberbullying
has gone up by 88% just
in the last five years
alone, and that the number
of repetitive stress injuries
for teenagers visiting
the chiropractor-- teenagers--
have gone up by 50%.
That's from a lot of this.
And I think that
it's interesting,
and it's changing the way
that we're thinking about how
are we as a society evolving?
What does that mean for us,
not only physiologically,
but also emotionally.
What is this doing
to our happiness?
Now don't be alarmed.
I know I'm in a tech space.
I love Google.
And I think that it's
important to reassure you
that I'm not anti-tech,
that I'm also not going
to tell you that
you need to throw
your phones out the window.
I'm actually a huge
fan of technology.
I believe it has
so much potential.
But part of my
mission and my message
is to help us use technology
in our personal lives,
as well as their
professional lives, in a way
that fosters mindfulness,
in a way that
elevates our emotional
well-being and our happiness
for the long run.
Because I believe that the path
that we are setting ourselves
on right now, right
here today, is
what's going to determine
how we feel in the future
and what our world
looks like today.
Currently, what we struggle
with is overwhelming
social media feed.
We have news coming
from all sources.
Our Twitter feed is
constantly coming in.
You've got e-mails that
are probably piling up
while you listen to me talk
about not being stressed out
by technology.
[LAUGHTER]
And you have to go back
and answer all of them.
We have Netflix feeds that are
now creating a backlog of shows
that we're going to
have to catch up on,
because they're releasing
all the episodes at once.
And these things begin
to stress us out,
even though they're things
that make us happy, even
though they're
things are supposed
to drive our productivity.
We find ourselves feeling
more and more overwhelmed,
frustrated, and
unprepared for how
to deal with the onslaught
of information in our lives.
So the question that
I want to pose today
is, can our happiness
and our health
keep pace with the
speed of innovation?
And I think that
the question really
comes down to a bit of
self-awareness on our own part.
Oftentimes we'll feel like
victims of distraction,
that somebody keeps texting you
when you're trying to focus,
that so and so keeps
sending your messages
that you don't care about,
that you're getting bulk email
messages or junk mail or
junk phone calls that you
have to deal with.
But the truth is that
sometimes we actually
invite those distractions
into our lives.
How many times have you
ever been in a conversation
with a friend
where you're having
this really deep, important
conversation, and all
of a sudden you hear
a beep, and they say,
oh, excuse me for a minute.
I got to get out my phone
and check this message.
And your moment of
quality time is lost.
Those moments
happen all the time.
And get a load of this--
there was a survey
done recently,
a national survey of smartphone
users, that asked people
how often it's OK to
pick up their phone.
And not surprisingly,
about half of people
said it was OK to pick up
their phone during dinner.
About half the people-- it's
a little more surprising--
say that they will pick up
their phone in the bathroom.
Get this, a third of
people, a third of people
said it's OK to pick up
their phone during sex.
I think this is the moment
in which I realized, OK, we
have a problem.
We've got to talk about this.
There's something
going on where we
feel like we need to be
needed, where it feels so good,
and so addictive,
other people find
our attention valuable, that
they need to constantly come
after us.
And there's a reason why we
continue to feed into it.
So what is that, and what is it
doing to our emotional state?
What I find happening, from a
positive psychology standpoint,
is that so often we are chasing
after this emotional high
that we are literally running
ourselves off of what I
call the happiness cliff.
And the happiness
cliff is that moment
when you are surfing
your Facebook feed,
and you're really enjoying
connecting with your friends
and your family members.
Seeing oh, that cute
kid just started school.
And oh, this really
important article
just came out that I
need to check in on.
About 30 minutes in,
you're still surfing,
and you don't even know why.
An hour, an hour and
a half, there you are.
And what happens
is that we cross
the point of what I call the
point of diminishing return,
which is that point
at which we passed
our maximum utility
for using technology
to increase our productivity,
and then we went off the edge.
So that point, actually,
if you look at this graph,
it's really interesting
to me that the point
of highest productivity comes
before the peak of the curve.
But the point at
which people realize
that they've fallen
off the cliff
is way on the other
side of the curve.
So what I'm going to do is
to help you think through
how do I recognize both,
in terms of emotion
and through my
physical body, how
do I recognize that point
of maximum productivity,
and then be able to
train myself to stop
before I fall off the cliff?
And that's a skill
set that I think
that we're just now beginning
to develop and emerge with.
Because these are
challenges that we've never
had to deal with before.
We're in an area where
we've never had boundaries
that we had to create for this.
And all of a sudden, we as
a society are recognizing,
OK, I think it might be
time for some boundaries.
I feel that.
I just don't know
what to do about it.
So what I want to do is to
bring you to positive psychology
and some of the time tested
strategies and principles
that we learned from
the field that I
think can be really, really
helpful to understanding what's
going on in your
own mind and body
and what you can do about it.
So how many of you
grew up in the '80s?
Raise your hand if you
grew up in the '80s.
Then you might be familiar
with this old ad that used
to be part of the war on drugs.
It said this is your brain.
This is your brain on drugs.
This is my take on it.
This is your brain on too much
technology, where you literally
have fried it by letting it sit
on your computer for too long.
So that's the mental
image of what happens.
I also like to use the
analogy of a sunburn.
And a lot of people say,
well, how long would
you recommend that people
should be on computers?
Like, the American
Academy of Pediatrics
now advises or used to
advise that children
between the ages of two and ten
spent no more than two hours
on computers a day.
And over time, they
started to change that.
Well, you know if they're in
school that doesn't count.
Or if they're talking to family
members, that doesn't count.
What we're finding is there's
a lot of gray area in there
for what is acceptable
for time on the computer.
And not everybody hits the point
of frying upon their computer
at the same point.
Just in the same
way that some people
sunburn at different rates.
My skin is pretty fair.
I know I sunburn pretty much
every time I walk outside.
My husband has a
much darker skin,
and he can handle
a lot more sun.
But what's happened
over time is we've both
learned our own bodies.
We know that I have
to use sunscreen.
I know when I'm feeling
burned and that it's
time to deal with it.
And my husband knows that he
can just go outside and not
even have to worry about it.
Those biological
symptoms become so
crucial to shaping
my behavior, changing
what I'm doing with by
preventative measures
as well as recognizing
signs and symptoms.
And so I think
what we need to do
is start recognizing,
when does our egg start
frying on the laptop?
What is that point?
And how do we get away from
it when we hit that point?
You might think well,
what's so bad about it.
I mean, I might play around
the edges a little bit
now and then.
I might even have to be
on my computer for work.
So I can't cut
back on the amount
of time I'm on the screen.
Let me share with you the impact
or destruction in our lives
that's emerge, in
the past 10 years.
In the year 2013, The
National Information Center
for Biotechnology reported
that the human attention span
has now dropped below
that of a goldfish,
below that of a goldfish.
A goldfish's attention
span is nine seconds,
and a human attention
span is now eight seconds.
Now just let that
sink in for a moment.
It's crazy.
What that means--
[PIANO PLAYING]
--for us-- whoops.
Let me pause that for a second.
Talk about distraction.
What that means for
us is that there's
some really key
information for us
that we need to
process about what that
means when we get distracted.
And so to show you what
distraction does to our mind,
I want to show you
this two minute clip.
It's really fun
and entertaining,
and it'll give you a snippet of
an idea about what destruction
does to us.
Let me get back here,
and let you see this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hi, I'm Richard.
This is Sarah.
And we're going to
perform the amazing color
changing card trick with this
blue backed deck of cards.
Now, the idea is very simple.
I'm just going to spread
the cards in front of Sarah,
and ask her to push any
card towards the camera.
- All right.
OK.
Let me-- I'm going to go for--
this card here.
- OK.
Now, Sarah could have selected
any card at all from the deck.
But she selected the card which
is now face down on the table.
And what I'm going
to ask her to do
is show us which
card she selected.
- All right.
So the card that I chose was,
in fact, the three of diamonds.
- The three of diamonds,
OK, excellent choice.
That card goes
back into the deck.
Now I'm just going to spread
the cards face up on the table,
do a little click of the
fingers, [FINGER SNAP]
and you'll see that Sarah's card
here has now got a blue back,
not particularly surprising.
What's slightly
more surprising is
all of the other cards
have got red backs.
And that is the amazing
color changing card trick.
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hi.
I'm Richard.
This is Sarah.
And we're going to
perform the amazing color
changing card trick with this
blue backed deck of cards.
Now, the idea is very simple.
I'm just going to spread
the cards in front of Sarah
and ask her to push any
card towards the camera.
- All right.
OK.
Let me-- I'm going to
go for this card here.
- OK.
Now, Sarah could have selected
any card at all from the deck,
but she selected the card which
is now face down on the table.
And what I'm going
to ask her to do
is show us which
card she selected.
- All right.
So the card that I chose was,
in fact, the three of diamonds.
- The three of diamonds,
OK, excellent choice.
That card goes
back into the deck.
Now I'm just going to spread
the cards face up on the table,
do a little click of the
fingers, [FINGER SNAP]
and you'll see that Sarah's card
here has now got a blue back,
not particularly surprising.
What's slightly
more surprising is
all of the other cards
have got red backs.
And that is the amazing
color changing card trick.
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
AMY BLANKSON: Awesome.
So this, for me, is such
a great illustration
of how our attention
and our focus works.
What we're finding is
that, if you pay attention
to all the things
that are distracting,
your brain literally
has no power left
with which to process
the things that
are meaningful within
your environment.
So you're taught
that, in this video,
it cues you to focus
on the cards, right?
And you feel so
tricked at the end.
Like, I can't believe it.
Did anyone, by the way, see
any of the color changes
before I explained it?
I heard a couple of snickers.
I heard some people
were getting it.
So that's awesome, right?
But the ability to see the
bigger picture is so important.
Because attention has
everything to do with intention.
And if you're not
focusing on intention,
you can't pay attention
to the things around you.
And so that is what
mindful living is all about
in the digital era.
How do we get beyond
the distractions
so that we can focus in on
what is really happening
and the bigger picture?
Or to put it in another
way, one of the statistics
that I came across
in my research
was that the average text
message takes about 2.2 seconds
to come into your phone.
And that 2.2 seconds,
what we see happen
is that the error
rates get doubled.
2.2 seconds, you
double your error rate
on simple tasks like adding.
If you have a text
message that you send,
which takes an average
of 3.3 seconds,
it triples your error rates.
Now imagine the impact of
that on your productivity.
Get this, beyond that, every
time you get distracted
by your phone it takes
approximately 11 minutes
to return to the focus on the
task you were doing before.
So that text message that's now
doubled your error messages,
has now stolen 11 minutes
of your productivity
that you could have been doing
other things with in your life.
So how do we get over that?
A lot of people immediately
turn to a digital detox.
I feel so saturated with
technology in my life,
I just need to get away from
it all for a little bit.
Now, that strategy
is very effective
if you want to simply detox.
But what we found is
that just like in diets,
short term diets ultimately fail
because they're only short term
interventions.
And I think what we need to do
is be able to create patterns
in our life for dealing
with technology in a way
that we can live alongside it,
that not only makes us happier
while we're in the process,
but will make us happier
for the long run as well.
Because just like the cavemen
who discovered fire back
in the day, right, they
knew it was dangerous.
But nobody once suggested,
let's get rid of fire.
I think fire is a
really bad idea.
It burned me the last
time I touched it.
No, you simply learn how to
use the tool better so that you
can then be able to take
advantage of the power that
comes with it.
And that's my approach
to technology.
If we're able to begin to
use this tool for its best
and highest purposes,
then we'll be
able to capture the
power for ourselves
as opposed to getting burned.
So the key here, we've
got to figure out
how do we stop using
technology to zone out,
and how do we use it to
start tuning in on our life?
Because I really
sense that there's
this bifurcation
[? that it has ?]
that technology is
either one or the other.
There's no middle ground here.
Either it's causing
us to move away
from our goals and
our priorities,
or it's helping us
move closer to them.
And so I have five strategies I
want to share with you briefly
today.
But I'll give you some takeaways
that you can just immediately
put into action in your own
life that are very simple,
but I think are very
eye opening as well.
And the first one is
to know your stats.
Now the average smartphone
user checks their phone
150 times a day.
Now you may think, well,
I don't check my phone
100-- there's no way.
That's crazy talk.
Maybe not.
But if you did, the
average smartphone user,
if it took them one minute
to pick up their phone,
check the message and
put it back down--
that's ignoring the
11 minutes of trying
to get back to the task
before that-- so just assume
one minute.
That would be the equivalent
of 2 and 1/2 hours of your day
just picking up your phone.
Which is crazy-- if
you multiply that
by the 12 months
of the year, that's
38 days a year of your life that
you're picking up your phone,
not even doing anything,
just picking it up.
If you don't believe
me, I have a great app
that is worth checking out.
It's called Realizd.
And Realizd has been
really insightful for me,
and generates a lot of
aha moments for people
I speak with as well.
It's a free app.
And what it does is it simply
tracks your phone usage
in the back of your phone.
Now your phone has ways that
you can do this on your own,
whether Android or iPhone.
But what I like about Realizd is
it gives a lot more statistics
behind your usage of your phone,
including how many times you've
picked it up, how
much time you've
spent every time
you picked it up,
what apps you were on for the
longest, what you were using,
what your patterns
are over time.
And it was most
eye opening to me
when I was doing
research for my book.
I'm going to be very
transparent with you.
This is my real data right here.
This is my real data during
Thanksgiving and my daughter's
birthday.
So the numbers by
the little clock
there should be green if
you're in the good zone.
They're yellow if you're
in a caution zone.
And they're red if
you're not doing well.
Red was my daughter's birthday.
That's six hours on the
phone, doing who knows what.
Maybe I was videotaping
to capture the moment.
We'll just assume the best here.
But what I think is
interesting is that at no point
did I actually dip
below the 2 and 1/2
hours of pickups that were
the average smart phone
user for the day.
My lowest amount of time is
two hours and 37 minutes.
So this was a really good
litmus check for me, to say,
OK, you know, I thought
I was behaving one way.
Now I know for a fact
how I'm behaving,
and I don't want
to live like this.
This is not who I want to be
and how I want to spend my time.
I actually have a lot of other
things I want to be doing.
And if you're like me--
I have some great strategies.
My colleague Alexa
and I are going
to be doing a workshop
right after this
to talk about digital
time management
and how we can rethink and
reshape some of our behavior
patterns to recapture
that time in our lives
and what that looks like
on a very practical level.
But that's the first step.
You've got to know
where you're at.
You've got to get
real, and you've
got to create a baseline so
you know where your behavior is
and where you stack up
with where you want to be.
The second step is to tap
into your third prong.
Now, the third prong, just
like an electrical outlet
has usually two prongs on it.
If you add a third
prong to the cord,
you get a grounding
wire that begins
to channel and focus energy.
And so I call this grounding
wire your third prong,
to help you think about
what it is in your life that
are your set of guiding
principles and beliefs that
shape the way you think
about your technology use.
It may be something that you've
never even contemplated before.
If you're a parent, you've
probably thought about it
in terms of your children,
how you want your kids to be
spending time with technology.
But it took me
some time to think
through what does that mean for
me and what I want to be doing.
And one of the things that I
came across with me for myself
was that I'm at a
place in my life
where I really
want to be growing.
I want to be
learning, and I want
to invest a lot in my family.
And so my set of
principles and intentions
all began to gather around
that set of intentions,
that third prong that
shaped the rest of what
I'm about to tell you.
So some people who want
to set their intentions
have been able to come up
with a lot of great hacks
to make this a
little bit easier.
I have a great friend in Dallas
whose name is Raj Daniels.
He used to be CEO of a tech
startup called OpenTime.
And he once created
this phone box screen
that I thought was
pretty brilliant.
And it was this simple idea that
said, when he opened his phone,
it would have a picture that
said, am I moving closer
or farther from my goals.
So every time he picked up
his phone for about 150 times,
he would ask himself that
question, farther or closer
to my goals.
And so I've developed this
set of free lock screens
that, if you're interested
in trying to set yourself,
you can go and
download any of them
or create your own,
whatever it might be.
But the idea here is simply
that you create something visual
that makes you check yourself
every single time you
go to your phone.
And I'm focusing on phones here.
I know there's many other
forms of technology,
whether game systems or VR or
computers, a time for work.
But I think for right now and
where we're at in our society,
phones are a big deal.
They're our lives, mushed
together with work,
and play and learning,
and we never escape them.
And so I think it's
really important for us
to think through, if
we're going to live
our lives in some symbiosis
with these devices,
what does that look
like, and are we
going to check
ourselves to make sure
we're going where we want to go.
Some of the intentions I've
heard from other people I speak
to is that my intention
is to use my phone
as a tool, not as an escape.
Or my intention is to check my
email only three times a day.
Because scientifically,
that's been
proven to be more effective
than checking constantly.
My intention is to not turn on
my phone at family dinner time.
Or my intention is to
look people in the eye,
rather than at my screen.
Particularly when I'm meeting
with a friend for coffee,
or a colleague, that I'm
not going to have my phone,
constantly looking at it.
I love having that conversation.
I think each one of those
is so important to shaping
your behavior and the
way you want to be.
And we found through
positive psychology
that if you take a moment to
write down your intentions.
Just for a second-- it takes
less than two minutes to write
down what your intentions are--
42% more likely to actually
stick with your positive
behavior change
than if you didn't.
So write it down.
Write it huge.
Put it somewhere very prominent
in your life that would really
help you out, to help you
stick with your intentions.
The fourth strategy is to
simplify, simplify, simplify.
Now we do this in our homes.
There is constant de-cluttering
and springtime cleaning, right?
But oftentimes we
don't take the time
to clean up what I call
our digital graveyard.
And this is the
items in our closets
that I'm pretty sure everybody
in this room has one.
Their old videotapes,
their old game systems,
there's cords and
wires, you don't
know what to do with them.
They begin to creep up on
you when you least expect it.
You have no idea
what to do with them.
Some of your old
laptops that are broken,
have sensitive data.
What are you going to
do with all this stuff?
What I find is that, if you keep
this stuff around in your life,
not only does it
impact your happiness,
but it begins to
create an effect where
the longer you hold an item, the
harder it is to get rid of it
later.
In fact, trying to separate
yourself from an item
has the same effect in your
brain as actually getting
a cut or a wound.
Excuse me.
So when we're able
to simplify, when
we're able to really
cut down to what's
most important in
our lives, that's
what begins to
create space for us
to make way for
future happiness,
to begin to bring in
new technology that
might begin to help us.
And if you're looking
for some really fun tech
strategies for how to recycle,
to upcycle, to reuse or to get
rid of items, I have a lot
of strategies in my book
I'd be happy to share
with you as well that
can help you begin to deal
with your digital graveyard.
I think it's a really
important topic
that I'd like to start having
the conversation around.
And last, we need to
establish invisible fences
at home and at work.
How many of you out
there have a dog?
Raise your hand.
Ooh, lots of you, yeah.
So when I was in
Virginia, I had a puppy.
And we had a yard that
didn't have a fence.
Apparently, for those of you
who live in suburbia of Texas,
we all love fences, right?
It's like the Container
Store for backyards.
Everybody has their
own little square.
But in Virginia, there were
just these sprawling backyards,
and people didn't put up fences.
And I was, I
confess, that person
who let their dog
just run wild, chasing
the mailman and the pregnant
ladies and their strollers.
And I didn't understand how
everyone else's dogs were
so well-behaved, until one day I
discovered the invisible fence.
And the invisible
fence is a system
that people started using where
they put an underground wire
under the grass, and
they put a little collar
around their dog's neck.
And what would happen is, if
the dog crossed the line where
the wire was, it would give them
a gentle vibration or shock.
And they'd learn over time that
they shouldn't cross that line.
What was interesting
to me, though,
was that the invisible
fence company
said that 80% of people
who have invisible fences
don't have them turned on.
Which is crazy, right?
What happens is your dog
learns where the boundary is,
and they just never
cross it again.
This is my vision for what
we might become as a society,
for ourselves and technology.
We didn't have
boundaries 10 years ago.
Now we're beginning
to create boundaries.
And we're trying to
figure out where do we
put that boundary, what should
the boundaries look like,
how much shocking do I
need to stop this behavior?
And then, how do
I stick with it?
But the idea would be that,
if we can train ourselves now
with appropriate boundaries,
that later on, down the line,
we won't have to have
so many shocks or so
many burns from being
overexposed, overused.
In particular, I find this
very important for children.
Those of you who have children
or have nieces and nephews
that a number of young
people are stumbling on
websites that, as
we all know, are
out there that we don't
want them to have access
to at this age.
I happen to have a 10-year-old,
a 7-year-old, and a 4-year-old.
And I was testing out a
new device recently called
KidsWiFi.
And I kid you not,
literally five days
after I installed this, my
daughter, who is 10 years old--
she's a fashionista, she loves
looking at things on YouTube
for fashion--
she came running to me.
And she's, like, Mom,
the internet's broken.
I said, sweetie, what
were you looking up?
And she said, well,
I was just looking up
cute girl, short skirt, and
the internet wouldn't work.
[LAUGHTER]
Whew!
Thank goodness I had just
tested out this device.
Because who knows what
she would have seen.
I guarantee it wasn't going
to be what she was hoping for.
But that for me was an
amazing beginning step
at an invisible fence.
I wasn't there.
I can't catch all
the moments when
she might have searched
for things that I don't
want her to be searching for.
But I'm beginning to
use technology as fire
to fight fire so that
I've got boundaries
around that keep us not
only safe but also happier
and healthier for the long run.
And that was a
really important one.
Another boundary that
I've heard a lot of people
say is that they've
just learned when
and where to have their
phone within their presence.
A research study I
came across last year
said that the mere
presence of a cell
phone in your line of
sight when you're working
decreases your focus,
your productivity,
and your effectiveness.
Now that's if you don't
even look at it or touch it,
which is crazy, right?
You would think that, maybe,
if you're picking it up
constantly that would happen.
But this is if you
don't even look at it.
Just the mere presence of
it in your line of sight
makes you less productive,
less focused, less effective.
And so the simple tweak, the
simple invisible boundary
here is simply to
hide your phone
while you're trying to focus.
It means putting it
behind your laptop screen.
in your bag, or if you
have nowhere else, to stick
it in your back pocket
so that you don't have
it in your line of sight.
It's the simplest
invisible boundary
that I know of, but
the most effective.
Because we know, scientifically
now, that this is something
that affects our brain, and
it is shaping our behavior
as we speak.
So try it out.
I encourage you to
try it, to share it.
I'd love to hear your
stories about how
that goes for you as well.
So we talked a little bit about
how technology can keep us away
from things that are
causing us to zone out.
But how do we use
technology to help
us tune into ourselves better?
Because this is a whole
new frontier that I think
is so fascinating.
It's amazing that we're
living in this time and space
in our world where
we're beginning
to see the cognitive
revolution collide
with the technological
revolution.
I love this picture.
This is actually a
picture of my dad,
who is a neuroscientist
at Baylor University.
And this was a photo of
him back from the 1970s.
He was considered
quite avant garde
for having living brains
in his office for years.
And everyone was
totally grossed out
by these brains in formaldehyde.
But he was fascinated with
looking at the human brain,
because at that
point, nobody had ever
been able to hold a brain.
That was really cool.
Now we're in a Technicolor
world where we're not
only able to hold the
brain, but we're actually
able to manipulate it, to see
it, to track it, to study it,
to see what's going on
when our brains are firing.
And for me, that begins
to help us peel back
the layers of our
brain and mind to begin
to create behavior change.
Where we know there
are certain things we
can do that will
change our outcomes,
that will make us happier
and more successful and more
effective and more focused.
And so this is where
I think technology
becomes the most
helpful for moving us
into the future of happiness.
Now to show you exactly
how important this is
and how this works,
this is where
I want to do an experiment
with you that I am really
looking forward to.
So nobody is required
to do this experiment.
I'm no longer allowed to bring
consent forms to my talks
anymore after that last
electric shock therapy snafu.
So this is totally up to you
if you want to participate.
But if you do, I need you
to move around a little bit,
and everybody needs
to find a partner.
So I'm going to
give you a minute.
Everyone find a partner, and if
you need one, raise your hand
and I'll partner you up
with someone in the room.
But find someone you can
do the experiment with.
How many of you,
raise your hand,
if you have a background
in psychology?
Anybody in here-- a couple, one,
two, three, four, five, six,
OK, great.
So for those of you with a
background in psychology,
this is what I call
the emotional prime.
And for everybody
else, this is nothing.
Don't worry about it.
So for the last several years
of your life, the last decade
of your life, you've been
developing your self-control
and discipline.
That's why you are as effective
as you are here today.
And so what I want you to
do for this experiment is
to use all of your self-control
and your discipline for just
seven seconds, and
at eight seconds,
you can do whatever you want
to, or with your partner.
But seven seconds I
need your attention, OK?
So person number one, what
I want-- oh, first of all,
I need to tell you who
person number one is.
So if you're sitting
closest to this wall,
you're going to be
person number one.
And if you're sitting
closer to this wall,
you're person number two.
So person number
one, raise your hand.
Person number two, great--
that was not the experiment.
That was just the setup.
I did this experiment on
Wall Street a few months ago,
and it literally took
them five minutes
to figure out who
number one was.
So I always just verify, now,
who number one and two is.
It's not a statement
about who you are.
But person number one,
what I want you to do
is turn, and get within striking
distance of person number two.
Person number two, I don't want
you to move to defend yourself
from bodily harm.
Don't flinch.
Don't move your face.
Just sit there and take it, OK?
You ready?
OK, person number
two, I want you
to look at person
number one in the eyes.
And person number
one, your job--
well, actually person number
two first-- person number two,
your job is to keep your
face as still as possible,
showing no fear, no
flinching, no frustration, OK?
Person number one, your job is
to look into the eyes of person
number two as deeply,
warmly, and genuinely
as you can, and smile the
biggest smile you've ever had.
You're trying to get the
other person to smile.
All right?
Go.
[LAUGHTER]
Bingo.
Ooh.
OK.
Hold it.
Person number two,
what happened?
That was horrible.
I mean, you held out
for longer than anybody,
but you eventually broke, right?
What I'd like do
is try this again.
I want to see if the other
person can retaliate.
So person number one, let's
see if you can keep your face
straight for seven seconds.
Person number two, your
job is to look them--
up into their ideas
as warmly, deeply,
and genuinely as possible.
Go!
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AMY BLANKSON: I see.
I think that was maybe
worse than before.
How many of you failed
miserably at this experiment?
Yeah, I thought so.
How many of you successfully
did what I asked you to do?
One, really, Nick?
Wow.
Two, three, four.
AUDIENCE: I'm cold hearted.
AMY BLANKSON: Wow.
The truth comes out.
What's so interesting for
me about this experiment
is it shows to me how the human
brain is wirelessly connected
to each other.
How one person could
smile at another person,
and even though they're
actively resisting you,
it's still able to create an
emotional connection there.
Which is amazing, right?
How many of you either
felt your own lip,
or you saw your partner's
lip, start to quiver
during this experiment?
Raise your hand.
OK, that's weird,
but totally expected.
What's happening there, and
this is phenomenal to me,
is that your motor neurons are
fighting against your mirror
neurons.
So your muscles in your face
are fighting against your brain,
literally trying to
stop you from smiling.
And they begin to quiver because
they're at war with each other.
And you see it, in just seven
seconds, begin to take place.
This is what's happening
in the human mind
as we begin to connect our
minds together in a room.
What we're finding is that
positivity and negativity
within a room can go from one
side of the room to the other
in under two minutes.
Or if you're at an airport
gate, and you really
want to try an experiment
to mess with people--
don't tell anyone I told
you to do this or to try it.
But there was once
a research study
done where there was a
research confederate placed
at an airplane gate.
And the research confederate
had about 15 people
standing around him.
And all he did for
two minutes was look
at, his watch repeatedly
bounce up and down,
and occasionally do the
uh, [HEAVY SIGH] sigh.
And what began to happen
in under two minutes
was that 11 of those
15 people began
to copy the exact same behavior.
We begin to mirror each
other through a room,
whether it's positive or
negative, because we're
emotionally connected
to each other.
And this, to me, changes how
and why it's so important for us
to begin to shape the way that
we interact with technology,
with each other.
With the wires, whether
wireless or we're not wired,
the ways that we interact
as a species and as humans
begins to shape the way
that we begin to create
the future of happiness.
Because it changes both
our emotional awareness
of each other as well as shaping
how we begin to create emotion
affect within the community.
Next week I'm going
to get to go to MIT,
and they're doing this amazing
emotion awareness summit,
looking at technologies
that will begin
to use the camera on
your phone or your laptop
to study your
facial recognition,
telling you through 11,000
valence points on your face
about whether you're feeling
joy or sadness or frustration.
But what they're
using that for is
to begin to create an emotional
connection with technology
that says--
imagine, if you were
sitting at your office desk,
and it could say--
you know, you've been sitting
at your desk for so long now,
and your face is
really beginning
to show frustration
or stress or anger.
Why don't you take a break now?
At which point, you might
want to hit your computer.
But I think that that kind of
sensitivity and thoughtfulness,
to begin to tie an emotion and
humanity into our technology,
is going to be where the future
and the frontier of happiness
is moving towards.
And I'm really excited to
see how do we shape that
through active conversation.
And additionally, we can
begin to use technology
to train our brains for greater
awareness and happiness.
The idea of being able to peel
back the layers of our mind
comes right back to
tracking our own behavior
through life logging or
simple things like Fitbit.
I love my Fitbit because it
helps me track, over time, not
only my eating my
health, my sleep,
but this is just the
beginning of the frontier.
As many of you know,
health trackers
are just the most
commercialized at this point.
But there's a number of amazing
gadgets and apps and devices
I've had the opportunity to try
over the last couple of years.
For the course of
my book, I wound up
trying out 400 different
apps and gadgets and devices.
And I literally had my skin
pricked for blood testers.
And I've had my body
vibrated from shock therapy
that was gone awry.
I've had Velcro adhesive
rip off part of my skin
for a posture trainer.
I've literally got my skin
in the game at this point.
[LAUGHTER]
And I find that
what's so amazing
is that despite
the fact that there
are so many misfired
technologies,
there's some really phenomenal
ones that are beginning
to create change in behavior.
Whether it's Happify,
that trains your brain
for greater happiness through
simple little games that
are free online, or
it's apps and gadgets
like Spire, which helps you to
track your breathing patterns.
These are the beginning
places for beginning to think
about emotional awareness.
And I put up here a
website, if you're curious.
I've got another 40 of my
favorite apps, gadgets,
and devices that I've
personally tested out now,
that I find to be particularly
effective for training
the brain for greater
happiness or well-being.
That's at AmyBlankson.com/Tech.
And I think they're fascinating.
If you know of others,
I'd like to learn more.
So feel free to share
with me after this talk,
because I'm curious.
But I mentioned
this Spire stone.
This is one of the gadgets
that I tried out last summer.
And it went from just a
fascinating gadget wearable
to fundamentally
transformative for me.
Of all the gadgets
and wearables,
this is probably the one that
I stuck with the longest.
And the reason why it
became so important to me
was that my 10-year-old
daughter, she was nine
last summer.
Through a series of
unfortunate incidents,
she wound up breaking her
neck last summer in our pool.
Fortunately, she's fine now.
She's back to doing back
handsprings and flips
all over the place.
But at the time that
this took place,
it was a dramatic
moment for our family.
And I had that privilege
of being the one
to drive her to the hospital
to meet with the doctors
and get fitted for
this neck brace.
And what was
interesting was that, it
was a time I was
testing the Spire stone.
And so all the way
to the hospital,
the Spire stone showed that
I had been completely calm.
It was perhaps that, like,
mother instinct calm,
where you're thinking
like, OK, this is go time.
I've just got to
take care of stuff.
But it wasn't until after we
were leaving the hospital,
that the Spire stone
started to vibrate,
and it sent a
message to my phone.
And it said, Amy,
you're feeling tense.
[LAUGHTER]
I know.
But in that moment
of recognition,
it made me think about
why I was feeling tense.
And what I realized was
that I was feeling tense
that other people in the
hospital were looking at me
and wondering what
kind of mother
I was that my daughter's
neck was broken.
And that was the dominant
thought in my mind.
But I recognized that that's
not who I wanted to be.
I wanted to be the mother who
was there for her daughter,
contemplating her summer
of having to wear this neck
brace, and what people
were going to think of her,
and what activities she
wouldn't be able to do,
and how hot and
sticky it was going
to be in Texas with this neck
brace on, and yada, yada, yada.
And I think that that
moment of self-recognition
helped me to mindfully
pivot in about 30 seconds
to be the person I wanted to be.
I could recognize I
was feeling tense,
could understand why
I was feeling tense,
and I could change my behavior.
And for me, this is
technology at its finest,
beginning to raise
our consciousness
to create lifestyle and
behavior change so that we
can be who we want to be.
And that, my friends,
is happiness.
That, to me, is the beginning
of creating a path in which we
can create change that
we can create together,
that we can create
something that we can make
a difference in the way that
we become aware as a humanity,
as a group of humans to
create that ripple effect,
the mirror neuron
effect in our brains
where we see change happen.
I think if we do
nothing in the future,
we're perhaps on
a trajectory where
we're heading towards a
future where everybody
sits at the dinner table
staring at their devices
and not interacting.
If you're like me, I
don't want that to be
the end of our story.
I think that we're just
at a crossroads right now,
and we're able to begin to
move through that to something
better and more powerful if
we use technology for the best
and highest purposes.
And I bring this slide
to you because you guys
are the innovators, right?
Google is at the top
of the food chain
for creating innovation
and positive change.
And so I want to
encourage you not
only to innovate, but to think
specifically about well-being.
We're not just about creating
smart cities these days,
we want smart and happy cities.
We don't just want
smart schools.
We want smart and happy schools.
So how do we use innovation to
feed and funnel more change,
to create and continue to
think about our humanity
and our connectedness
and how we're wirelessly
connected to each other.
And I'll conclude with this.
I think that, while
sometimes people think,
well, I'm just not an engineer.
Like, you know, I
might work at Google.
But I'm not one
of the people who
creates the gadgets and
devices or the new game
changers in the field.
And what I want to encourage
you is that each one of us
are innovators in our
own space and field.
These days all it
takes is one person
with an idea to begin to
create positive change.
It takes an idea to
collaborate and be
willing to put yourself out
there, to bring people together
around an idea.
And this story for
me is powerful.
I read this about
this organization
called Enabling Our Future.
And it's an organization that's
a global alliance of volunteers
around the world who build
3D printed prosthetic
hands for children in need.
So instead of spending $200,000
on a prosthetic arm, now
kids can get one for $30,
printed at their local library.
And so I told a friend
in my neighborhood
who has a daughter who was
born with Symbrachydactyly.
This little girl
is seven years old,
just like my
daughter, who's seven.
And she loves gymnastics.
And up until this
point in her life,
it's never stopped her from
doing monkey bars or cartwheels
with the best of them.
But as she's getting older,
her body is getting heavier.
And she found on
the monkey bars,
she was starting to
get painful blisters
from trying to grab the
bars in unusual ways.
And so I told her mom, you got
to check out this organization.
It's kind of fascinating.
Maybe it could help her
grip this gymnastics
bar a little bit better.
Well, one week later,
I get this phone call.
She said, Amy, you've
got to come over here.
And I said, OK, I'm coming.
What's going on?
And she said, well, my
husband and I checked out
that website you told us
about, Enabling Our Future.
And my husband spent the entire
weekend at the Frisco Library.
He printed a hand
for our daughter,
and I wanted you
to be here to see
her use it for the first time.
Oh, it was amazing.
I get goosebumps every
time I think about it.
Because it was the story
of one website that
led one father to
go find a resource,
to find a 3-D printer, to
begin to create a change
for his daughter's life.
That is a story I
can now tell to share
with you to go find other
people to find resources
to do similar things.
And it's a story
grows and changes
with time as we begin
to see that technology
is a magnifier, right?
That website was magnified
into community change.
And these things that we do
in our lives, these ideas
and innovations we come
up with, are up to us
to change and decide--
are we going to let
technology distract us?
Or are we going to
tune into ourselves,
and use technology for its
best and highest purposes?
So I encourage it, and I
leave you guys with this torch
and mantle to think about
what does this mean for you?
What would it mean to
create the next innovation,
whether in your
own personal life
through setting your
intentions, or beginning
to change the way that
you use your phone,
or beginning to
think through an idea
and build a collaboration
around something
that brings more humanity to the
way that we interact together?
So thank you so much for
giving me this opportunity
to speak to you, and
I wish you the best
as you go out there and create
great change for the world.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]